[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
funding we're seeking from council will
not be enough to develop the hub in its
entirety and we need to work hard to
find outside funding
that said i understand that the writer
foundation and the department of
internal affairs have expressed an
interest in supporting the hub
development
in addition the seed funding from msd
and potentially the council does make
the project much more attractive to
third party providers
as mentioned we're working on a draft
funding strategy to help fill the gap
between what council might provide and
what we might need for the hub
we plan to bring this draft back to the
committee later this year
if funding through the long-term plan is
unsuccessful and the project does not
progress
the need for the activity space remains
all the partner groups will still be
looking for space for their activities
these groups are unlikely to be able to
afford to buy or rent private sites
and will be potentially looking at
council land there are limited options
in caipo
for this that do not require some level
of investment to make them happen
it's a big ask for the groups to fund
their own buildings and this will be a
significant financial challenge for them
staff will continue to work with the
groups and support them in this regard
but there is a risk that they can't get
enough funding to locate at the hub
there's also the risk that while a
smaller community smaller scale
community studio facility was shown in
the kaipoy reserves master plan we have
not yet consulted with the enjoying
neighborhood
the proposed hub would see a change in
the landscape they currently have from
unused rural land
to a site with activities in people
while we intend to maintain a wide
buffer through the residential
properties
access from courtney drive and control
the type of activities and buildings on
site
the proposed hub is still a change to
what the neighbours are used to
when we updated the kaipoi tuahiwee
community board last night on the
progress of the hub
project they provided some valuable
feedback and i'll just note those key
points that came
from that meeting so concern was raised
about the potential spreading of the
community hub over two sites so that's
to the north and south of charter street
this is something we'll look to explore
further in the development of the draft
master plan
but the thinking behind this was to make
sure we retain sufficient space for all
the
hub activities now and in the future and
to enable that low intensity style type
development
this will all come through in the draft
master plan later on
concern was expressed about getting
underway with consultation with the
adjacent neighbours
on charter street weiber place and
dawson duglan's place to introduce the
residents to the project and to keep
them informed
by talking with the residents early even
without the project confirmed we'll
hopefully avoid this being seen as a
done deal
this is something we've started thinking
about and how we might go about this and
if the committee may wish to consider a
recommendation to this effect for this
report
there was a question around what might
happen if the groups could not afford to
locate a building at the hub
and this is a very real risk and one
that exists for all the potential hub
groups
as mentioned it'll be challenging for
the clubs to raise funds to enable
building
but there are a couple of actions that
we're trying to do to
go towards alleviating this risk the
first is the preparation of a draft
funding strategy to coordinate and drive
applications to third-party providers
it's also considered that approaching
providers as a hub would be more
beneficial than individual applications
and already we have had rata and the dia
express interest in the hub
the second measure is continuing to
support the groups in seeking and making
funding applications
and through the community team's
expertise we have we have that on tap
that we can
help our groups with a question was
asked about whether the croquet club had
confirmed their intent to transfer the
murphy parkland to council in exchange
for the new lawns at the proposed hub
and while the hub
while the club have been engaged
participants in the planning and design
process for the hub and indicated in
principle that they wish to relocate
we have not had formal discussions on
the transfer of the land
the proposed letter of intent to the
club which is attached to this report is
intended to get these discussions
underway
moving forward should the
recommendations in this report be
accepted we will continue to develop a
draft master plan and user obligations
and funding strategy with an aim to
bring this back to this committee
and as we've been doing we will continue
to work with the groups on the design
and the planning of the hub
and provided we can secure funding of
having the hub site ready for buildings
in 2022
and rachel and i are happy to answer any
questions you may have
ah thanks michelle and i might be wrong
here but originally i
heard that the food secure people had
something in the order of 650
000 could be wrong on that no you're
quite correct um that was for the total
application for the project for food
security not
not for buildings so the proportion of
that that set aside for building
is the 250. yep
okay my second question is on the land
itself
which presumably has been transferred
from linds into council ownership what
happened to the land covenants
that existed on those smaller titles
because the rest of courtney properties
will still have the benefit of those
and they control the quality type etc of
buildings
and they might not be happy with
relocatables
my understanding in dukkha might have to
jump in here is those were cleared at
the time of divestment from
lynn's router council thank you
just a question on the waimakariri food
and budgeting forum
does that incorporate all the groups
within the waimakariri
that are in in food rescue and food bank
type of work yeah so what's happened is
um the food and budgeting forum
with the money that's been um that we've
managed to secure from
central government um we've
moved it into a group steering group
called food secure north canterbury
which is that forum
an adaptation of that so we have
representatives from
food rescue and food forest and food
banks
and facilitators in that space in in
february next year i think it is yeah
february
we're going to actually open that right
up to
a plan for the district to all
stakeholders so that's community
pantries community gardens anyone who's
interested in that
food and education space for the
district so yes
those people are all involved and have
been from the word go
yep
because i was aware food forest doesn't
burn the banks food banks and is this
bringing everybody together
under one move yeah thank you very
collaborative
thank you just talk referring about the
food banks
um there was there was one in oxford so
would they be part of your one as well
even though it's at quite a distance to
travel down
to get food to bring back up to your how
do you work that
okay so i know they had trucks excuse me
i know they had problems during the cove
at time it was a lot of travelling so
just what what's your plan okay so
a big part of this collaboration is
supporting all of the food banks in the
best way that it can happen
and so part of the money was to purchase
has been used to purchase new freezers
and things
as opposed to just the building to
support and strengthen those food banks
and groups
satisfy food rescue as a as a major
partner in this
project as you're aware and so they're
also developing we're supporting them to
develop their
systems and things to enable that food
distribution
across the district a lot easier
bearing in mind the entire goal is that
there isn't
a strain on our food banks and
supermarkets in five or ten years
because of this work and food security
for the district
thank you is is the 400 in any of the
prep
ltp documents that we've seen
it is
would you like us to strengthen up the
the consultation process would you like
us to add a recommendation in there
okay i'm happy to do that with the
committee's um
approval from the chair shall we add a
you could modify
g or we could just leave it there and
add an h
saying something like recommends that
the staff are authorized to
commence immediate con
call it pre-consultation with all
affected residents that cover it
is everyone happy to add that because
with um
where are we d if we as soon as the
letters are well it was a public meeting
anyway last night
and as soon as we send letters of intent
out um it's it's out there and we need
we need to be moving
fast so that the the residents are
saying what the hell is going on we
weren't told
so all right so i'll add that did you
get that h down
to you all right so i'll move with that
addition i'll move
a h a to h from the chair the second
five seconds um speaking to it not
much to add michelle's covered at
excellent presentation
um there's a few fishhooks in there the
buffer thing but
she's worked on that very hard the
finance of course is
who knows crystal ball gazing and the
and um
but we we've worked very hard to make
sure that the thing if it does go ahead
is future-proofed we think of north
brook which is full
and nowhere to expand we we've tried to
think 10 15 20 years ahead
so an excellent presentation philip
thank you mr chair um yes comprehensive
report michelle
um my main concern was delayed when uh
chris said that it had been factored in
to our draft lp
ltp discussions uh that got it over the
line in my mind
um apart from that i've got nothing else
to say at the stage um
we'll see how consultation works out
and how the ltp pans out
hmm thank you so the purpose of this
report is always is to update the
community and recreation committee
on a summary of aquatics year-to-date
progress i'll take the report largely as
read however wish to highlight a couple
of key areas
so the attendance figures in the report
cover the period of august
and september 2020 which as you'll
recall were both months that the
ministry of health imposed covert level
2 restrictions for part of
we are now back at regular levels of
service however as identified in 4.1
attendance
numbers are down overall due to
restrictions on ongoing programs at
level 2.
likewise in 6.1 financial implications
the effect of covert restrictions on the
business are evident
the operational income result was under
budget due to low numbers for programs
swimwear sales acrobatics and family
admission
which are all areas that were impacted
by the level two covert restrictions
a number of maintenance works have been
brought forward and completed which saw
a spike in year-to-date spend
however this still falls within our
annual planned maintenance budget
the result for operational expenses
comes from two key areas
electricity and learn to swim staffing
as the ambient temperature decreases
over winter the plant has to work harder
to heat the air in the water within the
facility however this is balanced by
less effort and therefore less spend
over the summer months
and ultimately should end up meeting
budget
despite covert restrictions council must
continue to meet
its contractual arrangements or staff
and to ensure that this was
their time was still of benefit these
staff were re-homed to provide
assistance to teams
within council who saw greater covert
workload
with examples being the customer service
and library teams
however following talks with the cdhb
restricting program activities will no
longer be a
requirement if we move back into level
two
as detailed in item 4.3 staff have been
in talks with the
canterbury district health board to
better understand the ministry of health
guidance and how it applied to our
activities
following much discussion we reached the
point where they agreed that it was
likely our program could continue
so long as we met the following
stipulations that all other guidance was
adhered to
including contact tracing physical
distancing of groups and a head count of
less than 100 within the facility
in the event that anyone contacted
coverd all staff and program customers
would be considered
close contacts requiring isolation and
most importantly we would need to
maintain a watching brief
with the intention to potentially change
our approach to address the degree of
community
transmission what this ultimately means
is if that we are
to find ourselves in a similar situation
to previous where auckland
had community spread and our district
didn't
that we would be able to still run
programs
and i'm happy to take any questions
it's just just on the electricity and i
imagine it's been asked and
answered before is with that fantastic
big roof you've got there
have you had have we done the um
the costs and benefits of going solar
i believe it was done when the facility
was
designed and found that option was found
wanting it hasn't been something we've
looked at since but it is definitely
something we can investigate
definitely changed since that i mean
you're talking what are
you talking 10 at least 10 years um
and suddenly every man is
every person in his dog has got solar
because it's some
price of it has dropped and you've got a
north facing big roof is it north facing
no it's not
anyway um yes and battery storage
i mean it seems to be the way of going
is there anything
i mean when would you when would the
council staff actually review that
to see whether it it is worthwhile
on a facility like like the pools or
dudley
we're still working with main power at
the moment in regards to the
stadium originally when we had
conversations with them
the answer was no not really there's no
real cost benefit because of the capital
investment and actually putting it in
we wired the building up so that it's
actually easy to connect into solar for
the future because we have the
um pergola veranda whatever you want to
call it out front
um and
north carolina recreation trust and
the stadium i know i'm getting to that
i'm getting to there
um uh north carolina
ricky ash trust and craig um have
continued conversations with main power
and
um since since we started conversations
to now the technology has changed um
and it's become cheaper and there is the
potential that we might be able to get
some
at the stadium so um if we can do it at
the stadium then it might be that we can
do it somewhere else and we don't i
don't know what to what level
main power would be um putting that in
um as a loss leader or
or advertising or a project for people
to say you know
for a community good um but we'll know
more and we'll get more results out of
what happens in that building um and if
that shows that it's
promising easy to do then we can
investigate and bring a report back
around
other facilities
the water unit looked at it a year or
two ago didn't they
for um and turned it down for is not
economically feasible too but then as
chris said the technology changes every
18 months
once again thank you very much for your
report it's um
great to see that things are moving
forward and you're starting to um
lift you lift your um number of people
going into the
not lit to lift literally but lifting
the number of
people that are going into the facility
so that's great news and
for the summer months and you've
obviously got a new summer program that
you're thinking about
bringing out so that's good news too
thank you
and my tuppence worth thank you matt um
a trying time and we're
and since post covert and we've we're
impressed with the way you've handled it
especially all that close contact
rubbish shouldn't use that word
that you've had to put up with and
getting back onto a level level keel
so i'll put or adoption all those in
favor say aye
against carrie thank you
radio we are up to tessa
6.3
thank you um
so my report provides an overview of the
community teams year in review
report for 2019-20
and it includes an overview of the
approach
applied to the work of the community
team
and in particular it details the top
five achievements
along with key aspects of the 2019
20 years work
and this of course has included the
covert 19
response and recovery planning and this
formed a
key aspect of the work of the team over
that period
um
i'll take the report as read
and i'd just like to take a minute to
acknowledge some of the more general
things that highlight the value of the
special
and really genuine relationships
that have resulted from our work i'd
also like to
highlight the collaborations that have
been
particularly strengthened and or
developed as a consequence
of some of the challenges that were
presented by the covet
event so i just want to talk about some
of the amazing people in our community
a real a real standout was that we
had people in places in this district
that we could
send people to for immediate assistance
over the event so nigel from salvation
army
who we met on zoom and is now a mate
that we meet in the street
he was always there he popped the
chocolates and the food parcel for the
woman who had family
who was experiencing family violence and
had to be put into a motor camp
nothing was any trouble five o'clock on
a sunday night he was available
top bloke we knew that we could call on
vicki lucas from presbyterian support on
a saturday afternoon and that she and
her husband would willingly pop around
and see an older man
at a makeshift motor camp to make sure
that he was linked into these services
and the supports that they had available
we knew that sarah saunders from waita
health
also was linked up with the pegasus
health people
and and that she could do a little work
around so that
a woman who was going out of her mind
with schizophrenic
um paranoia could be
linked into immediate help we knew that
joe from oxford trust was going to
follow up on someone with extreme
anxiety and suicidal
ideation just with a chat to follow up
from the conversations that we had had
with her
so that that was a real local community
lincoln that there would be follow-up
support afterwards
we knew that we could ring crete at the
mirai to reach out to the frightened
motor camp residents
who had nia to uhuri whanau and the list
goes on
all of those special people working in
our community who go
above and beyond their usual work to
have real
connections with people that really do
make a difference in their life
you know it's really great that we can
directly
link those struggling with addiction
housing issues and mental health issues
without the wait times in the red
support that keeps people on the street
that's a really special thing about this
community
um so in terms of of our team you know
this
there's all that there's all of those
little um other duties as required
things and we really like that we can be
a trusted port of cool call
for people like some of our local
personalities
who pop in when they're overwhelmed
or when they've got something exciting
to tell us about
we don't want to become an agency and we
don't you know that's very secondary but
it's really special
and along with the library we're a place
for a friendly hello on a monday when
hope's closed and we really appreciate
that people can kind of go through the
two it's lovely
a number of partnerships have developed
and really strengthened
as a result of the kova 19 event and
we're increasingly seeing
people coming together and thinking
outside of the square
to make things happen and link things
together and
examples of that are the the seeking
help of strength website development
and linking that in with some community
connective funding that's going to
connect people with the local social
services
as well as working parties for food
security meaning stronger connection
and support for hironui and it's been
really great to be able to
develop that relationship with haranui
community development
given that a lot of the agencies that
provide support here are also working
across the highway district and we think
that we can really add value there
without it being
an onerous thing at all digital
inclusion has got people who've been
rather siloed really starting to work
together and and you know some exciting
things happening in the library space
and
and um are thinking outside of the
square and working with high schools and
and places like senior net and citizens
of vice bureau
all things that are really going to add
value to the people in the community
schools and food banks citizens of vice
bureau who
who were really very much an information
um that set in there in that office
with people coming to them are really
applying an outreach
approach now and we're really excited
that they're coming to the collaboration
hui that we have
coming up on thursday enterprise north
canterbury
have connected with us wanting more
pastoral care
wanting to offer pastoral care support
alongside practical support for local
business owners and that's great
because it's one thing to get business
support but if you're suffering hugely
from anxiety and depression you need to
make sure that you can be linked in
msd wanting to partner around well-being
related to job loss and
youth council are really looking uh
quite proactively
in being involved in youth unemployment
and that's been driven
by uh one member of youth council in
particular and the chair of youth
council
and and in brand new thing is the art
center really
thinking it's the arts sector really
thinking outside of the square and
considering opportunities to collaborate
um
for increased profile but also for the
greater good
which is which is really cool and they
very much enjoy the recovery
for him um so so particularly this year
we have loved and continued to love
the banter the laughter and the genuine
caring
and the creativity and drive that are
ever present in the network steering
groups and project
groups that we have the privilege of
facilitating and supporting
so while this report documents the work
of the community team
it really celebrates the incredible
contribution of the various
geographic communities and communities
of interest that make up the district
this is a really great community to get
a bunch of like-minded
to get people together to roll up their
sleeves and get things done
um this sort of collaboration results
in an incredible array of community-led
initiatives
and um report details some of those
and that really exemplifies the value of
collective wisdom ability and talent
martini mamano karapa
te many hands make light work
and unity is strength
uh thanks tessa i'm never cease to be
amazed at the number of groups working
out in the community
with you um those people you referred to
have they been or their being
acknowledged in some way
um absolutely so so the annual report
um if you if you read the introduction
it specifically acknowledges that it's
not
just about the work of the community
team it's very much about the small part
that we play sometimes a large
much larger part but um the part that we
play in it acknowledges the work of the
community so all of those networks are
detailed
in the annual report as well yeah i just
wondered if
they'd been sent letters or or something
to personally acknowledge
yes they are so so the reporters um
circulated to our partners with an
acknowledgement and thanks for
their contribution to that work
they understand exactly the amount of
work that your team puts on
so that's just something to think about
i don't know how you feel about that do
you
yes yes um and the other one i just want
to ask
please um is the migrants please um
i'm just interested in um how they are
fearing with
um the the rules that the government has
now
put on on their their uh how much money
they have to earn to stay in the country
so i'm just wondering how that's
progressed with that one
um so that was discussed at the migrants
group meeting last week
and particularly oxford
out of oxford community trust have
an element of migrant support and they
are inviting large employers of migrants
to engage with them around the
implications
for their people immigration new zealand
have been quite
good at communicating and offering
um support and i know that we work very
closely with
tony tony yeah
right thank you um because that is one
thing that i'm a little bit concerned
about
and um and i know that they are
hamstrung by what they can do what they
can't i can probably add a little
little bit extra to that in that um
there is
assistance available for repatriation
and
that immigration new zealand are working
with employers
around that too so um
we denise has done a really good job of
scouting out what's available in terms
of support for migrant workers and
she'll continue to do that
that's excellent the other one question
now is the drug harm
education how well did that go was it
very successful
right throughout the whole district yes
it was um i think that's right
you've got it referred in there yes yes
so is it the school's embraced
it the schools and the parents the
school's embraced it really well we've
we've
um had some feedback we we put an
evaluation through there there were a
couple of things a couple of
recommendations for next time
but we got very good feedback from the
students and the teachers alike and i
know that there was
some quite rich conversations a really
good thing that came out of that
was the establishment of a parent
support network
which um sounds great yeah you know
parents can be
horribly shocked and not know where to
start so there's been some good
conversations
and there's also a quite a strong we're
now established to look
at um drug harm or
support for people suffering from
addiction both youth
and adult oh that's that's really good
because having had
a brother that got onto drugs and things
like that and
serious drugs um the the effect on the
his parents was and knowing elderly
parents was horrendous
so i'm really pleased to see things like
that happening yeah thank you
she done my accolades to you so thank
you very much
i just like to congratulate you on
an amazing amount of work that you've
gotten through and i
cannot i cannot say enough how proud i
am to be part of a council that that has
a team like this
and for the very tiny part that i have
i've
sat in on and and been part of i
the work that you do in liaising with
our community
in virtually every corner of it is a
testament to the beating heart
of our of of our community of our
district
and i can only take my head off to you
and i especially
would like to stress d notes the
collaborative community-led approach
adopted by the community team and i
thank you
he's um just having attended hcsw
yesterday i was absolutely astonished to
hear that
this district as an employment has
actually reduced the amount of people
who are actually seeking jobs in the
last month
or so and a lot of that has been due to
collaboration
between everyone from msd to the high
schools
to the community team to employers to
enc
so what we are doing is we're finding
that you are providing that glue
your team nikki and everybody in it are
providing the glue to link all those
groups together that traditionally may
have done great work but maybe
separately and so now we're seeing a
cross section that we're having to
actually
breach those gaps and that we need to
link in the business community with the
community sector and
it's working really really well and so
um i i just every time i see a report
like this
it it just highlights the fact that we
have been incredibly fortunate
to have your leadership and the
leadership of
the management team who've allowed this
to
become a focus of this council and i
think it's very hopeful
uh for the future and that shows how
important local government is
to link all these groups together which
could not be done on a central basis
i'd just like to endorse uh councillor
mealing's comments
i also feel proud to be part of this
council because a lot of your work that
you're doing is actually not seen
people see potholes and roads but you're
working
almost invisibly but i think making a
difference so
it's a very good report and thank you
i'm just trying to remember what that
saying is but it's it takes a
it takes a village to raise a
student a child and this is exactly how
this is in a
wider scale so well done
thanks for having me um the purpose of
my report is
to brief the committee on an update on
usage activities and developments within
our district libraries
i'll take the report as largely read but
i'd like to draw your attention to
several points of interest from the
report if i can
you'll note that waimakariri libraries
have received funding from the new
zealand
libraries partnership program which is a
covert recovery package
initiated from minister martin from
department of internal affairs and the
national librarian bill mcnaught
it recognises the increased role of
libraries
and librarians to support citizens and
communities with the ongoing
impact of covert particularly in the
areas of employment assistance
assistance with processes related to
applying for government
services and benefits computer
upskilling
retraining and use of library spaces
services
and staff for social connectedness
not since 2007
when the creation of apnk which is the
aotearoa people's network the free
internet access and wi-fi that was
delivered to public libraries
not since then has there been a central
government injection of this much money
into libraries across new zealand so the
library sector is
quietly euphoric about what was offered
at the end of may
unsurprisingly why maker library
submitted bids
applications requests expressions of
interest to every pot of gold that was
on offer
and we secured as you can see from the
notes
funding for two fixed term full-time
21-month coordinator positions
we secured a two-year fee waiver from
some of our existing charges and
procurement costs that
are collaborative library services
provided by the national library
and we also pushed our luck strongly by
applying for four places
on a nine month national research and
evaluation program
that is facilitated by an
internationally renowned
researcher from the uk and we secured
four places on that
more than any other library service in
new zealand
the nzlpp aims to support 170
full-time jobs and public libraries
across new zealand
and as of this afternoon i'm really
proud to say that
two waimakariri libraries staff have
been offered and accepted
roles which we've called community
connections coordinator and digital
inclusion coordinator across the country
60 councils have been given the
equivalent of 119 positions
and it's expected by christmas that 170
roles will be filled
we still have one more application and
for a combined role between the
community team and libraries
at this point i'd like to acknowledge
3.1.18 and the strong collaboration
between tessa
supporting our bid for the community
connections role
and work with the interviewing so that
we've got really
strong relevant synergies between what
the community library
community team are trying to do and the
libraries team are trying to do
minister martin at her press briefing
said that libraries have an increased
role in supporting communities
with cvs jobs and retraining but she
said it's important that you don't stop
peddling those little packets of magic
called books and acknowledge the
increased role that libraries have in
community well-being
and we are seeing that so strongly last
friday in the library there was not one
table
free at rangiora library for anybody to
come into
we were full with elections with people
sitting
people being people learning so this is
going to be an amazing thing for our
district
we're back we're going to backfill the
roles
and we'll be going out to public market
for for those library assistants
it was very important to me that we
retain this
expertise this training opportunity and
this experience
within our existing staff and not open
it up to
other areas to to apply and then leave
again with that knowledge
if i could draw your attention to 3.4
so the 20 19 20 learning connections and
orientation services obviously covert
has challenged libraries to rethink how
we deliver
learning programs and events
but despite everything that's happened
including the measles outbreak in that
calendar period where we still delivered
805 events and programs
to just under 18 000 people
we have had a shortfall of just over 2
000 people
attending events but none of our data
includes the online programs
that we de we created and offered and
locked down
so with a team are understandably very
happy
and i'm so proud of what we're able to
do it shows the need for the sort of
roles that
the sort of outputs that those two new
coordinator roles
will create and the demand for those
services
yesterday at kaiapoi library we normally
have two
three at a stepping up program which is
your absolutely
most basic computer program we had nine
turn up for that for a free drop-in
session so
you know the demand is out there and if
i can finish with something warm and
fuzzy 3.2
and introduce you to hazel our new
library reading dog
chris said i absolutely had to report on
this
so hazel's a three years 33 year old
malty poo and she's absolutely delicious
she's um there's a lot of research
around reading
to an animal reading to a dog and some
libraries actually have a large soft toy
and children with stutters with dyslexia
with um
belief in themselves not that they can
read aloud that a dog or an animal is a
very neutral
uh audience and um last week we had a
beautiful
story with a 12 year old who had no
belief in herself
and read for 15 minutes straight to
hazel
um so hazel will be our one of our team
on um thursdays at kaiapoi and tuesdays
and rangiora and we put it on facebook
as a
join up put your name down to be part of
it
the most popular facebook post within
about within two and a half days we had
5923 hits on that one post on our
facebook
page so
she's beautiful so
so thank you take questions if there are
any
thank you very much for your report once
again
stunning um the community connection
uh coordinators will they go around the
whole three libraries or they based in
all three libraries so we've we're
really taking
the idea that we are a network we're a
district-wide library service
but will that person that role will go
beyond the
three buildings um and go out into the
community where the community
are our big thing for that person was
they had to have wu
they had to be able to win others over
and engage them
um and identify groups and that can push
we can push to the light push to them
that the library is a platform for what
they want to do in our spaces
so the person we've got um has
definitely got that
excellent and the other question i just
want to ask please with the
i know that the ringura burra school is
using your library and there was a big
contingent outside there the other day
which was fabulous um how long are they
going to be
going to be doing that for because it
just made such a wow
thing to it isn't it tactfully answering
how long's the ministry of education
redevelopment programme last
benefit it is definitely for our benefit
so that was pushed out a bit longer
pre-covered
um and i haven't touched base with how
long
we're curious but not wanting to sound
like how long is this going to go on for
because we're loving having that energy
that that rise and fall during the day
so between 11 and 12 and 2 and 3
classes are able to come over um
sometimes for
independence you know browsing looking
at the gallery engaging with start at
whatever they're wanting
so um i'll touch base with the principal
towards the end of term four
and see how their rebuild of their
school library
is going my other question is from that
one
are the children really embracing this
going to the library and and
choosing books and and engaging
absolutely
and also we're trying to get them
engaging with more than just
the area of the library so that amy
hallmark's created some really lovely
mystery trails
so that the kids find places in the
library that may be of interest to a
parent or an older or younger sibling at
home
so the idea they go home and share so
people are coming back and we're getting
enrolments
from family members are dragging me down
here after they came here on a school
visit
so wonderful thank you
ah thanks paula i think this is another
one of the successes of the district
on page 108 in diligent
you've got a summary financial report
i note that the deficit is significantly
smaller than budgeted
which seems to be caused by increased
revenue i just wondered what's the
source of the increased revenue is it
the other funding
sources you mentioned that hasn't come
into
our um that hasn't that fee waiver
hasn't come back into the waimakariri as
yet
i'm still working through with paul
christians and how we will deal with
that because we will invoice
paul will set up a new cross centre and
invoice dia
for that funding reimbursement um so i
missed what you said about the
i couldn't quite hear the first but you
said about what line
oh sorry i've got it black and white
line
two on page 108 the revenue
the actual um is 20 plus
thousand ahead of your budget okay we
had kids fest
and the revenue from those from the
tickets
for the events the few events that were
sales
would have caused a spike but by the end
of the year
into the financial year that'll balance
out kids feast as our pro
our primary revenue earner um for
the year i was hoping you were heading
towards a
a positive figure
you know me i'm all about social return
on investment
once again thank you very much for that
very good and detailed report and
the work that you're doing with the
children your group are doing with the
children is
fantastic it's not just children it's
the the older age group as well that
you're helping and assisting and it's so
good to see
it branching out into the three
libraries it is
yes yeah network-wide yes excellent so
and i'm i'm really pleased that by the
look of it that you're embracing the
the home school children and the is
having activities for them which is
really important
well done and well then that goes back
to your whole team please
yeah they always get a feedback after
this meeting with every compliment
that's shared yeah thank you
right thank you um
it's hard to know what to say really it
it's a library that's adapting
and moving forward to new circumstances
and it's not like the library i remember
when i was at school
and university i'm almost getting
enthusiastic to go over and read to
hazel
[Laughter]
we can make a special slot for you it's
a very good report paula and um i i
think we also have a library service we
can be very proud of
thank you thanks
i just have to put my two cents in worth
because i
always look forward to your reports
they're always good news
stories they again are another thing
that we can be so proud of because you
know
our libraries thanks to their leadership
are
are so much more than just books again
they're a living breathing space that is
integral to our community and building
community and i just always take my hat
off to you and the team for the amazing
work you do
and i'd like to congratulate you on your
success with
the funding and the waivers and the in
the positions that you've gotten as well
because
those are some great wins when they say
contestable funds they generally really
mean contestable so that's
that's phenomenal so well done and thank
you keep up the amazing work
love your work
just a question um and you may have
covered it before
paula so the heating system is that
i saw some contractors there also around
the water cooler
which was to be provided for the public
if we looked into that any further i
didn't see it in the last time i was in
there
the hvac system started installation
last monday night
monday the 12th was the on-site
induction
with the radiators gone by tuesday
morning
they aim to be finished by the end of
november they've got about a week buffer
in there once they're all set up and we
know where
everything has been repositioned i've
asked richard to get back in touch with
the
plumber who came in um to do the quote
for the water cooler
and just find where the best placement
is going to be because we didn't factor
that in
when he came in earlier in the year
great now
if it's right speak just just briefly
join the comments that others have
already made but
you do have an excellent team over there
paula and i
always love it when i go and they're
they're always so helpful and positive
and that's the remarks that we
get from our public all the time and
you're probably one of the most
public-facing roles that we have
and when we look at our community
services as community surveys it's
consistent the results
are achieved in there so it's just
outstanding so thank you to you and your
team
really pleased the heating's going to be
resolved that's been a personal priority
um in the the calling uh sorry the um
water uh drinking caller because it was
been raised with me by a few people that
have said that we need it so i
appreciate that being followed up
hopefully all by christmas excellent
well done
and very thanks report yeah and you know
what not to like
free stuff
thank you
no i'm just i'll just comment on it um
this group this group uh usually
met every six months but because of
various situations and that they
couldn't but with earthquakes and
whatever they couldn't meet
but now we've got on a regular six
monthly run and
um i just put that in just for you to
have a look at what the reports are
coming from our our museums are very
positive and also
have sent up the report up to the hirono
ones as well just for them
it's a good meeting good group to meet
with and they share
things of interest with one another and
promote to the
area so it's great thank you
portfolio updates with please i'm sorry
items hironoe reserve playground tenders
closed with staff reviewing the
submitted tenders
and will be awarded this week it is
planned to be completed before christmas
tara cartney and mandible toilets have
been awarded with contract
construction due to start on site
shortly these are both programmed for
completion prior to
christmas workers started on planning
for the toilet renewal at maria andrews
park staff
meet with club staff who are going to
invite them along to either
november or december meeting as they've
had several changes to their board
staff are working with supplier with the
supplier and the installation of a flag
track system across the district to
reduce ongoing operational costs
with the town centre flags the system
will make it much easier to put flags
up and down ongoing renewal of poor
assets throughout the district is
ongoing
staff are planning for next year's lt
ltp as well
in operations teresa lowe park banned
rotunda painted and steps about to be
replaced
stop bank lights raven key and trucelo
park
have been repaired repainting of rangara
cbd planter boxes happening today
as well as renewal of signs renovation
of
airfield taxiways painting of airfield
runway marker boards and perimeter
fences
new dog waste bin installed at pegasus
lake shore
softball diamonds at norman kirk park
will be handed over to green space in
the next week
security gates at norman kirk park will
be included in the locking schedule
in the next week and general green space
have engaged rsl to update
the sports facility plans all clubs have
been sent a survey and this work will be
completed in november to assist
in the preparation the ltp staff have
been in communication with several clubs
uh post the winter sports season and
many appear to be in relatively good
spirits despite the lockdown the sun the
shortened season
still had financial implications but is
not as severe as first expected in march
a number of tree planting thefts
recently as well as a spate of vandalism
on the toilet blocks this has gone quiet
in the last couple of weeks
however we are still seeing regular
incidents we have been
logging police reports with some success
on a few occasions but generally it is
difficult to identify
the culprits thanks grant for assisting
me
those are always impressive reports i'm
just out of curiosity like
with the space of vandalism and that we
have i always know that whenever
surveillance is mentioned people always
um kind of
lose the lose it a little bit um
but is there anything that we can do
with regard to i don't know cameras or
any kind of surveillance or anything
that we can
um just in targeted areas that are are
always being vandalized to maybe
minimize it would that would they even
be a help
police wise we've got a number of
cameras here now
they were set up some years ago and uh
and
craig was overseeing it i don't know
whether you still are
so we do have some and on occasion
we can install in a hot spot
for example we had one in the fire
brigade
uh pointing across the toilets when we
were having issues but i think there's a
more permanent one
covering that now uh but it's through
you know
at the end of the day it comes down to
the resource of
one identifying the person and uh
yeah and follow up so there's always
issues but you'd be surprised at the
amount of times you are on cctv
cameras now
i could just add to that we have also
been working with um
uh the the community watch you actually
go into the police station i think it's
in kaiapoi
um uh for both rengar and kaipu now um
and and so there's actually people in
the community that go and watch the
screens and
um and we've been working with visual
networks who
maintain them and put them up to take
one get a better maintenance program for
them so they're actually clean so you
can see better
but then working with those community
groups and visual networks to
create a map which has been done at the
moment of where you can you know look
with a triangle going we can see this
far
um so that we can look to see if there
are any black spots or
areas which we would like to put cameras
in the in the future
and we'll bring that back to this
committee before we do anything with it
the most recent one has been i believe
one at the marine precinct in kaiapoi
that we've installed
and to reflect the fact that we've now
got people um parking
uh boats there with the first boat
now parked there as of yesterday
following on from that nikki there are
there are problems for instance brent
had
cameras at the food forest and they com
a woman
complained about the privacy issues of
being filmed and
and forced him to take them out you know
it's it's not easy and it's not cheap
he has a camera back in there now but
the camera
it just doesn't
an important thing for people to to
see and understand what a major quake
would be
the other one is that on the 23rd of
october
the um oxford at oxford again with the
um
the lions are putting on a mental health
awareness evening and it's with richard
lowe which is
he is with ag safe and doug avery so
we're hoping that it'll be successful
and the funding of that of course is to
go to the well-being of um
of men's health so there are two things
that um
perhaps if someone would like to if
you'd be interested in going to both
will be very good indeed
the other thing is um
i'll just stick this off oh age friendly
um
through my role as a justice of the
piece i'm actually finding
that a lot of the really older people do
not
now have any id at all because they've
lost it
the driver's license no longer valid
they don't have
a passport so they've actually got
nothing
that shows who they are with photo id
so i've asked queen and found out that
um there's a kiwi care
card available where that
the family could perhaps take taking
them down and get something like this
because this is becoming where they want
when they're going wanting to sell their
properties that they've actually got
because of this money laundering thing
they've actually got to show
who they are in a photo of them well
that's not quite so easy
especially when they're in a rest home
or something like that all about that
but
so this is um i just just feel it's
actually really important to get this
information out too
well i've got to find apparently it's
from you get it from
um new zealand post yes but i just need
to find a bit more
out about it but it certainly would be a
very helpful
sorry
something like that not really but but i
just think it would be
um it would be very helpful
um now moving on from my next one
of course um as as you know read the
what the
north carolina museum meeting in ambly
was very successful
um the stadium well unfortunately i
couldn't get to the
um the roof shout but i believe it was
very successful not for the shout but to
be able to go and actually have a look
around the
the stadium here and i'm sorry that i
couldn't go but
because i was really looking forward to
it um there are the arts
um creative communities and i will say
our
gentleman over here as the chair of it
now because i've done my
six years and but i was
very impressed with the applications
that came in
we usually have about 23 but this time
it was nine
but the the changing and what how
um people are applying for them now and
it's become more hands-on
and i'm really thrilled to see that the
children the
teachers asking for different things
projects for children to
to make and paint and like there's one
that's up at um
fernside they're going to the children
are going to paint a mural on their the
year around pool
wall so and also um
at west end and they also did that as
well it's just
looking at the different ways now
they're thinking about
what can the kids do to actually use
their hands and that's
i just think that's incredible i was
really impressed with that
um work um are they a pensioner flats um
gina's um been upgrading the pension
reflex and
in cowboy upgrading the kitchens and
bathrooms and
and putting new carpets in and
drapes and things like that and they're
all really embracing it so
um so that's that's good so some of
those
number those flats will be all updated
um we're also getting a bit of
double glazing done this epinox and
flats um
pinching the flats uh they a lot of a
lot of
double glazing has been done but the
doors and that are now being double
glazed as well
so we're just slowly working through
it's it's not a cheap thing to do but
we're slowly upgrading these
very old pensioner flats into something
that's a little bit more
user friendly for them in in more open
space like still the same place but it
looks like more open space and
far better um facilities for them in
their their showers and
things like that really safe so that's
me
for someone that left all my stuff
behind i've managed to
you mentioned
yeah unfortunately a lot of them don't
so this is where
a lot of them well they have a gold cup
but they don't have a photo with them
a lot of them don't yeah yeah but i just
thought i'd just mention this because it
is
um it is an issue a real issue actually
yes no exactly yeah so it's a bit like
the
the 18 card but for the for the 80 plus
people it is the 18 plus card yeah um
but the 18 plus card has been rebranded
as kiwi access card
reflects the fact that it's not just
people that are 18 that actually need a
card so you can go to the website kiwi
access.com
and it's got a whole bunch of frequently
asked questions around where to apply
and you can apply both aaa
and um and the post shop
that's a really good website thank you i
couldn't remember what it was called but
i knew it was a kiwi card
i didn't have to raise a point
under portfolio updates whether it might
chris
for you and perhaps um cheer to reflect
on there are a number of
outside bodies like um ymca health
advisory group
um youth council be really good to see
whether we in in the five i sit on waita
primary health for instance
i've just been on a um a zoom call with
cdhb and there's some things i'd like to
be able to update
council on at some point but to just
reflect on where that could go
and the agenda because there's some
really good groups that were out that
are outside that would be good to be
able to
um i guess uh give points back here so
kirsten
um nikki and i youth council and those
others so
just wonder if you could think about
that and where the health advisory group
does actually report back into because
um it's supposed to report back to
council
yeah so just